uh all right we're going to begin this
hour though with the airstrike that
killed al qaeda's leader ayman
al-zwahiri he was a key figure in
planning the 9 11 attacks and he'd led
the terrorist organization for the past
11 years since osama bin laden's death
as wahiri was killed in a u.s drone
strike in kabul ending a manhunt lasting
more than two decades in a speech last
night president biden said he gave the
final authorization for the strike and
there were no civilian casualties there
are concerns this morning about how
america's most wanted fugitive was able
to live in the afghan capital after u.s
forces pulled out last year for more on
that and what this means for the ongoing
war on terrorism let's bring in cbs news
senior national security contributor
michael morell he is a former acting and
deputy director of the cia michael good
to see you it's always great to see you
good to see you vlad
so let me ask you you were with
president bush on 911 you were with
president obama when he authorized the
strike that killed osama bin laden um
what does this strike mean
for the ongoing war on terror that began
on that horrific fateful day on
september the 11th
vlad maybe the place to start is with
the victims
of 9 11.
president bush kept a chart of all of
those al-qaeda operatives responsible
for 9 11 and he would cross off
individuals as they were captured or
killed
and
this weekend was the last person on the
list
and that was zawahiri and he was crossed
off so that should bring some degree of
closure to those victims of 9 11.
certainly the 9 11 families are most
likely the ones that are breathing a
sigh of relief including all americans
but i have to ask you mike given that we
now know that the taliban is
sheltering providing safe harbor for
terrorists should the united states be
worried about a retaliatory attack
so al qaeda
has
has wanted to use afghanistan to use
taliban control of afghanistan to
rebuild their capabilities they're
fairly weak there now but they want to
rebuild their capabilities and what this
does more than anything else is says to
them that we have to worry first and
foremost about our security even in
taliban controlled afghanistan because
the u.s can reach us there that will
make it more difficult for them to
rebound so that is a good thing that is
the main benefit
of this strike over the weekend
michael based on your experience from an
intelligence standpoint the knowledge
that you have
how is this strike likely carried out
yeah um nate um
three phases to this the first phase is
there's some there's some intelligence
there's some specific intelligence that
takes you to
um the site that took you to this this
building this mansion in kabul and then
once you're there
you spend a lot of time
um looking at it staring at it watching
the pattern of life
and you're trying to do two things
you're trying to make sure that the
person who you're actually looking at is
the person you think it is so is this
i'm in zawahiri
and then secondly you're looking for
opportunities to conduct a strike where
you don't take out any civilian
casualties and so you spend a lot of
time in phase two phase three then is
actually taking the strike when you're
given that opportunity
and uh michael you know they didn't
touch his family they didn't take his
family out in any of this it was just as
wahiri but he obviously had influence on
i'm sure younger people and his family
people who knew him um when you look at
that what's next and even though i know
you said their reach isn't that broad in
terms of al qaeda
is there
anything that we should be worried about
when you look at the big picture uh and
the influence that al zwari did have all
of these years since 9 11.
so i think it it it we'll see who
replaces him right it could be somebody
younger it could be somebody more
dynamic
certainly somebody who was influenced by
him
he was one of the most violent members
of al-qaeda when his egyptian group
merged with al-qaeda years and years ago
al-qaeda became more violent so to the
extent he's mentored the next leader you
know that that will tell you something
about that person
so i think that's the most important
thing to keep in mind is who replaces
him
what does that relationship with with
the taliban look like and how aggressive
will we be and will will we maintain our
focus on afghanistan and so far we have
and i hope we continue
michael royal thank you
you're welcome